bonjour daniel sinimalé aujourd'hui nous
expliquera comment concevoir une cuvette
autour d'un arbre
l'idée de la cuvette c'est de créer un
espace autour de larmes
en fait qu'il puisse récupérer tout le
du pli et de l'arrosage automatique pour
pouvoir se développer tranquillement et
pour pouvoir aussi développé des racines
en surface afin si on période des
cyclones ou de vent très fort il va
pouvoir bien résisté à ses voleurs voilà
ici pour la cuvette
je vais utiliser une petite hache est
ici une pioche donc afin de désherber au
tour tranquillement et sans animé l'an
la première et à céder de délimiter la
cuvette
c'est à dire je vais transféreront à
l'aide de la hache conseils pratiques
utilisées la main pour pouvoir mesurer
la couv est donc ici on va aller sur eux
10 à 15 cm de distance entre l'arbre et
la cuvette
bon
je vais désherber et délimiter tout
autour de l'arbre faut pas aller trop
profonde et sinon on va toucher les
racines et la ne sera pas très content
ah je vais désherber avec la main ici
tout autour de l enlever des herbes
ici donc ici quand je vous ai dit j'ai
fait à peu près une 10 à 15 cm voilà je
vais utiliser la pioche pour aller un
petit peu on profonde yeux mais pas trop
tu as dit à peu près 5 à 10 cm en
profondeur pour créer vraiment un effet
de cuvette pour que l'eau pointe elle
arrive au tour de l'armée va pouvoir
bien récupérer et surtout de se
développer les racines qui qui vont
pousser tout autour
les idées gens qui font qu'ils qui met
en but et la terre contre la bbc comme
ça mais on pourra pas appeler ça une
cuvette parce que vu que quand l'ol
tombera dessus donc l'eau pourra pas
pénétrer jusqu'aux racines
donc elle va s'évacuer tout autour donc
le mieux c'est d'enlever une partie de
la terre autour de l'arbre voilà donc je
vais toujours connaissez aussi ici à
l'aide de la main je vais retirer le
surplus de terre et le mettre autour
afin de créer un petit canal
déjà c'est un aspect esthétique déjà et
c'est un aspect de protection donc comme
ici on a du gazon con qu'on fait de la
tonte souvent donc ça permettra de delà
d'être protégés de duffy de la
débroussailleuse et de la tondeuse
donc c'est un aspect de sécurité aussi
polar moi je veux proposer une petite
astuce pour améliorer la décoration
donc on va pouvoir n'est des galets
minérale fait dire qu'on trouve dans les
dents les grands noms scène ici donc si
le couleur blanche gris minéral blanche
ou noire comme vous voulez sinon on peut
ramener des coupes de bois ou sinon de
deux des écorces de pin par exemple
aussi qu'on peut trouver dans les
grandes enseignes ou aussi de la fibre
de coco
donc ça fera un aspect esthétique et sa
garde à la surface humide donc bien
point info labre donc pour pour le
développement racinaire ça serait bien
aussi donc aussi pour l'aspect physique
aussi des fois il faut il faut trouver
le petit truc pour mettre sa touche de
personnalité dans dents dans cette
décoration là et toujours lui être
créatif en fait peu importe du moment
que ça fait joli et qu'on trouve jolie
c'est ça c'est ça le principal